[Gelächter]
Hamburg Fischmarkt kurz vor 5 in der
Früh Helga braucht eigentlich gar keinen
Kaffee um munter zu werden sie ist das
komplette Gegenteil eines morgenmuffels
mit ihrer guten Laune steckt sie alle
auf dem Fischmarkt an und hat hier fast
schon eine Art Promi-Status
wenn ich morgens losgehe sage ich immer
ich möchte ich freue mich und ich muss
nicht ich möchte aber ich will arbeiten
und dann sage ich auch noch nicht ich
muss euch mehr ich arbeite doch was viel
Spaß macht zu Hause wäre langweilig zu
Hause eigentlich nur ein Fernseher da
kann ich gar nichts machen
Helgas Arbeitsplatz aber ist kein
Marktstand sie betreut das Örtchen auf
dem Fischmarkt an den Sonntagen
gemeinsam mit ihrer Cousine Anja fast
jeder klogast bekommt von Helga einen
Spruch zahlt deine Frau oder zahlst du
gut hallo einmal 70 bevor sie reingehen
mal junger Mann macht alles klar bevor
sie nach Hause machen viele haben gerade
eine Nacht auf dem Kiez hinter sich wenn
es euch nicht geben würde wäre alles
scheiße
wird und da ist noch Glitzer im Gesicht
ne oder hast du da irgendwas dran ach
das soll das sein einmal 70 Cent bitte
oder hast du so einen Druck der Lauf
schnell durch es gibt keine bessere
Toilette wie hier am Fischmarkt gehen
wir mal gerne essen
Essen und Trinken pissen auch
mit 64 müsste sie eigentlich nicht mehr
arbeiten
also davon abgesehen aber aber trotzdem
also
ich glaube ich würde kaputt gehen wenn
das nicht so ist ich weiß nicht also ich
wenn ich zu Hause bin dann und liege und
schlafe dann kriege ich auch schlechte
Laune
Melli dein Kaffee wo bist du
danke mein Schatz wenn ihr Lachen über
den Fischmarkt schalt gibt es Kaffee
Helgas morgenservice für einige
Marktleute
oder oder Sims durch ne die passt in die
Welt und wenn man sie lachen hört und
lacht man gleich mit also ich lach gerne
ja heute Morgen war das auch wieder wohl
eine Sache trinkst keinen Mann mit und
so nee sag bringt nichts
das ist so
Helga hat auf dem Fischmarkt einen
Monopol es gibt nur diese eine Toilette
hier auch bei ihr ist das Pinkeln teurer
geworden
[Gelächter]
oh das ist nett danke schön
danke danke dafür mal durch er hat einen
Druck auf der Blase
der Job ist für Helga viel mehr als
wischen und putzen hier ist sie unter
Menschen und die bekommen manchmal sogar
ein Stück Kuchen nach dem kleinen oder
großen Geschäft da vorne alles gut da
vorne
gucken
[Gelächter]
es gibt Sonntage da ist es für Helga und
ihre Cousine auch weniger gemütlich
während einer Sturmflut mussten beide
schon einmal von der Feuerwehr aus ihrem
Klo gerettet werden
und wir haben uns dann im Schlauchboot
hier raus und war sehr aufregend muss
ich ganz ich bin auch nie im Schlauch wo
wir waren ja schon klitschnass wir waren
ja das Wasser stand ja schon bis bis zum
Tisch und es war doch ähm steht
Hochwasser in der Toilette das gehört
hier dazu ebenso Spülmittel in
Wischwasser für die Marktleute gibt's
bei Helga gratis danke
schön und die revanchieren sich
und hat mir einmal 70 Cent Bedingungen
gedauert hat mir gestern mein Auto nee
ist okay gehen Sie mal
reingehalten gestern hat mir so ein was
soll das immer diese Waffe und da hat er
so hübsche hübsche Himbeeren und so
drauf gelegt und so seit fünf Jahren ich
fühle mich immer alleine aber sie ist
wie ein Mama
ich komme immer vorbei das Helga unsere
Mama
seit zehn Jahren ist sie hier die Mama
auf dem Fischmarkt Klo früher arbeitete
sie auf dem Kiez als Tänzerin auch schon
mal nackt auf der Bühne früher als
Tänzerin mit boah du musst es einzeln
alles Aussehen du konntest tanzen auf
der Bühne du konntest nach deinem Musik
du musst es auch eine Geschichte haben
und das ist heute nicht mehr heute ist
es nur die Gegend gereicht mit oben so
halb Dinger drauf und und was ist denn
das das ist doch nicht mehr schön
also ich hatte eine Disco Lady gemacht
ne wenn wir mit der BEE GEES Musik von
dem Bee Gees weiß ich noch ganz genau
weil ich habe die Bee Gees liebe ich
heute noch Kiez Rotlichtmilieu
prostituiert hat sich Helga damals aber
nie denn hier ist das ja immer weil ich
am Nachtleben war als Tänzerin
Anschaffung gegangen und dann musst du
aber beweisen
dass ich das nicht mag deshalb machte
sie auch noch eine Ausbildung in einem
anständigen Beruf als Friseurin sie
hatte einen Kaffee ein Sexkino und
arbeitete in einer Bäckerei
heutzutage ist das Geld wichtig egal
welche wie viel Cent bitte schön alles
so zwei für ein guck mal hier für die
nächste Kinder
gehabt
ja du siehst ja richtig gut aus jetzt
[Gelächter]
mit der Zigarette vorne danke fürs
wieder aufheben macht nicht jeder
Cousine Anja löst Helga ab die nächste
Kaffeebestellung muss raus inzwischen
ist es hell geworden zu Helgas zweiter
Familie auf dem Fischmarkt gehören auch
diese beiden
das macht nichts finden
[Gelächter]
einfach jeder hier auf dem Fischmarkt
kennt Helga und den Rollmops auf die
Hand oder den Kohl für die Rouladen
bekommt sie von den Händlern auch schon
mal geschenkt
ja
Schatzi guck mal weg
so dreckige lecker dafür später
Sachen denken ich möchte das was du
jetzt da hast was du jetzt sagst
natürlich mein Schatz
[Musik]
hallo Helga hallo mein Schatz
wie geht's dir mein Engel gut wenn ich
jetzt mal Spargel kriegst du mir noch
besser
mancher flirtet auch gerne mal so ein
bisschen mit Helga mit ihren drei
Männern hat sie aber nicht so gute
Erfahrungen gemacht
nur einmal bin ich nach Hause kommen und
noch eine andere Frau dann da ne dann
bei dem einen war das so da habe ich
viele blaue Augen gehabt also na also
ist in einer nee lass mal wird fertig
mit den Männern mit dem Männern mich
fertig und gibt's andere Möglichkeiten
hallo Polizei
schon als Kind war der Hamburger
Fischmarkt für Sie anvertrauter Ort fast
jeden Sonntag war sie hier zusammen mit
ihren Eltern und ihren Großeltern
Tiere alles noch in der Halle das war
alles wunderschön aber auf dem
Spritzenplatz habe ich dann abgebrochene
Blumen von meinen Onkel und die habe ich
für ein Groschen das war mein
Taschengeld für ein Groschen verkauft an
die Rentner und so und so so hübsche so
abgebrochene Blumen das erwacht man
heute ja auch alles nicht mehr aber
früher war das so also und das hat mir
immer Spaß gemacht
[Musik]
ich fahre gleich ein kleines ich brauche
nicht so großes musst
Helga liebt sie ihre kleine Fischmarkt
Familie und deshalb ist sie auch jeden
Sonntag in aller Frühe gerne wieder hier
wenn wir unterwegs heute Glück ist für
dich wenn Menschen du um dich hasst so
wie ich im Moment die fröhlich sind die
ins Gesicht lachen und wenn einer
knuddeliges und ist halt nur für dich
dann lachig und dann ist er lachte auch
lass uns für mich Glück
lachen ist gesund
und wenn um halb zehn die Händler ihre
Stände abbauen und es ruhiger wird
bleibt Helga gerne noch ein Weilchen und
genießt die ersten Sonnenstrahlen des
Tages